hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played yesterday uh
in hikaru nakamura's stream
on chess.com and he plays against none
other than jimmy donaldson uh most of
you know him as mr beast and he's one of
the most popular channels on youtube
uh with the videos raging uh to almost
100 million views i think
i think maybe one of his videos even has
over 100 million views
and he's always been a chess fan uh i've
seen uh
chess sets and him playing chess in some
other videos i even
uh got um uh some footage like an hour
and a half of footage of him playing the
uh the game of chess on uh on the set of
one of his videos and i thought about
making a video on that one but it was uh
uh they said that set the pieces up
wrong they switched the king and queen
and then
it wasn't uh it wasn't an actual game
but other than that it was
quite fun uh but here he faces hikaru
and every game he faces hikaru they're
playing
eight minutes blitz games uh hikaru
takes off something over the board so as
you can see
here hikaru is playing without both
knights and the one of the pawns
uh and um i don't know i guess they're
gonna continue doing this
uh until you know i guess mr beast wins
at least one of the games
so this is one of the games i thought
was the nicest one
and uh let's uh check out what happens
here uh so jimmy with the white pieces
opens with d4
sorry about that uh we have bishop to b7
by hikaru now
also uh without the b7 pawn actually
there hikaru can fianchetto the dark
square bishop right away but uh make no
mistake this
position is already winning for jimmy
from the from the start
uh the engine is giving it over over a
plus 10. if for example
we had this position in a lila versus
alpha zero game of course uh
you would see a resignation here as
engines automatically resign when
there's a plus 10 on the board
so knight to f3 by jimmy and now e6 by
hikar preparing to bring the other
bishop into the game
bishop to g5 attacking hikaru's queen
and now
f6 hikaru brings it back of course you
can't play something like bishop to e7
because
uh hikaru being down material from the
start of the game
uh he does not want to trade pieces so
he wants to complicate the position as
much as possible
and wait for jimmy's mistake so he has
to go back bishop to e3
and now bishop to e7 he car ready to
castle he's going to bring the rook in
try to bust open the center
uh we have knight to c3 and here d5 by
hikaru
g3 jimmy preparing the fiance to his
light square bishop
and now hikaru castles and bishop to g2
so everything uh working out very nicely
uh
rook the c8 by hikaru and jimmy now
castle so
uh no mistake so far uh from jimmy's
side he's still on plus then
on the evaluation bar by the engine so
he's doing well
and he covers strikes in the center with
c5 with d
captures on c5 bishop captures uh and
here you
you can play a lot of moves but the move
jimmy plays next is a very peculiar one
he plays b4
uh probably to get hikaru to capture it
and to go something like rook to b1
to attack both of the bishops uh but
hikaru after this b4 move he just
captures an e3
and now uh with the b4 move being played
the knight and c3 is undefended
so here we have bishop captures any
three f captures
and hikaru grabs the knight on c3 and
okay he curls position now improved a
little bit
uh but uh of course uh white is still uh
winning in this position
uh so here queen to d2 attacking he
calls rook and he carry defense at queen
the c8
and also now uh threatening to pick up
the c2 pawn and here
uh jimmy doesn't even defend the pawn
rather he plays rook
eight to b1 he has uh he has a different
plan
hikaru captures the c2 pawn and here
jimmy just brings the rook
closer one more square rook beat the c1
and now he forces hikaru to trade queens
and to go into a favorable end game for
jimmy so let's see what happens hikaru
grabs the queen
jimmy does the same uh rook caltras and
c8 we have
rook captures on e2 as the rook on d2 is
under attack so rook captures on e2
and now comes rook captures on f8 with
check we have king captures on f8 and
now uh here it's not all that easy to
figure out an exact plan for white yes
you are
up a piece but black has a pretty
massive center here and
also black will probably very easily
pick up pick up these
pawns so probably your best bet is to
get the knight into the game
threaten the e6 pawn so you kind of
force rook captures on e3 and then bring
the rook over to control
uh the only open file on the board which
is the c file
however uh jimmy goes for a3 uh he gets
his pawn out of harm's way
and also defends the b4 pawn and now
rook captures an e3 hikaru grabs the e3
pawn
now attacking the a3 pawn and jimmy
defends it a4
we have e5 by hikaru and now comes
rook to e1 jimmy wants to trade rooks
and hikaru of course
goes uh for the queen side pawns we have
rook to b3
and again uh b5 the strongest move
recommended by the engine
by jimmy uh we rook the a3 by hikaru
going after that a4 pawn and now there
is no way to defend the a4 pawn you now
have to give it up
and play something something else
probably rook to c1 getting the rook to
the
only open file on the board is the way
to go jimmy on the other
other hand goes for rook to d1 he wants
to move this knight
and then put pressure on the d5 pawn and
also you will never be able to push this
pawn because the bishop on b7 will be
hanging
so here rook captures on a4 and
now comes knight the e1 now uh with a
double attack on this d5 pawn here
and here uh hikaru uh kind of trolled
jimmy he asked him uh what would happen
if i played
d4 here and now i don't know if jimmy
figured out what to do but he said you
you should kind of do it for educational
purposes but of course hikaru didn't do
it he defended it with the e4 move
and now uh what does white play here
knight to c2 jimmy now starts
bringing the knight into the game king
is seven he
starts bringing the king into the game
as you always should in an end game and
now
rook to b1 also getting the knight into
the game with knight to d4
would be an excellent move since it's a
dark square the light square bishop will
not be able to harass the knight it's
nicely defended the b5 pawn is defended
so a very nice solid move but we have
rook to b1
and now he allows d4 so now those two
are very very dangerous
pawns with b6 by jimmy he wants to bust
open the b
file and we have capture sun b6 with
rook captures on b6 and now
bishop back to a8 and now with the
bishop on a8 being defended
now black will definitely be able to
push a move like
e3 and here jimmy went for
bishop to f1 again the strongest move
recommended by the engine
so although he made some mistakes he is
finding uh some
viable ideas here so bishop to f1 and it
was around this position uh jim was very
low on time i think
under two minutes uh hikaru gave him
some time on the clock
which is also an option uh you can do
you know if you want
sometimes if you're really enjoying the
game and you don't want your opponent to
lose on time then you just give him more
time
uh and here he carl played f5 uh d3
or is also an idea just pushing that
knight starting to
get that pawn as close as possible to
the promotion square he cover played f5
uh now created a massive pawn center
here but mr beast has a brilliant move
here
that uh really makes it problematic for
black
to play this position so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this move for
jimmy while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting bishop
to b5
also for those of you uh i mean uh sorry
congratulations to everyone who found it
uh because it takes away
these three squares from the black rook
and now you have to move it away and
this pawn uh then falls so if the rook
moves for example rook a2 attacks the
knight knight captures on d4
uh black will have a very very difficult
time playing this game because that
that d4 pawn and basically the the
entire black center was the
was the trump card that uh hikaru was
going to use to win this game
however after this f5 move by hikaru uh
mr beast went for
rook to a6 he found the way to exchange
rooks and he thought okay
two pieces against one piece even though
you have a kind of a
strong center here i'm gonna take my
chances there so here
hikaru has to trade rook captures on a6
bishop captures and
now d3 attacking that knight we have
knight to d4 and now comes g6 as the f5
coin is under attack hikaru defends it
and now
knight to b3 here uh beast knows that
these pawns are coming forward and he's
trying to figure out a way how to defend
against uh those pawn pushes and uh he
finds knight to b3
of course you should you should always
start bringing your king into the game
uh in situations like these he finds
knight to b3
and now of course the d2 square is
defended by the knight and if you push
e3 then the d3 pawn falls so for the
moment he stops the pawns
uh but hikaru of course finds it bishop
to d5 he attacks one of the defenders of
the d2 square
and now knights the d2 not all that
impressive because you allow the pawn to
be pushed forward with tempo
so here king the f1 uh beast decides to
bring his king
into the game now and give up the knight
uh you could also try
something like knights to d4 to keep the
knight into the game
but then the the black king will simply
kick it away king f2 king to f5
and now not all that much for you to do
that
there if k3 then g5 is coming and uh
well if you move the knight let's say
knights to b5 then there are even ideas
of bishop to c4 and black is completely
winning
for example knight c7 you're gonna
ignore this and you're just going to
push this
and now the pawn and bishop prevented
the king from uh
approaching even the past pawn and
hikaru would queen on the next move
so here after bishop to d5 we have
kinked the f1
uh jimmy decides to give up the knight
on b3 to bring the king into the game
and now of course hikaru just grabs it
bishop captures we have king to e1 and
bishop to c2 now so all of a sudden
uh hikaru who was down two pieces and
the pawn is now
uh simply up for uh up three pawns
so h4 and now comes king to f6 he car
now just has to bring the king into the
game via the dark squares
g4 hikaru of course advances the pawn
bishop to c4
and here hikaru goes e3 so not much you
can do against d2 he plays g5
check king to e5 at this point uh hikaru
is just bullying jimmy but jimmy said
that even though he could resign he's
going to continue for the
for the fun of it as uh uh of course
they were having a very good time so
here
h5 by jimmy d2 with check king to f1 and
now
d1 with queen and now of course it's a
forced mate in two
uh king to g2 with bishop d5 with a
bishop to a
sorry wrong bishop bishop to e4 with
check uh king moves and now queen to h1
is
checkmate as the white king has nowhere
to go
so really a wild game and uh this was
very very close a few moves uh from
jimmy you know prior to
blundering those pieces uh it seems that
uh there are just too many pieces for
jimmy to handle
so as he started losing more pieces he
started
finding better moves so we'll see i
wonder
how many pieces can they take off the
board because as you can see here
uh they played uh he carplay without the
two knights and without the b7 pawn
next game uh this was the next game they
uh played the hikar with the without the
two knights the b7 pawn and the h7 pawn
so i guess the
the bishops are coming off next and then
uh
would be fun to see how far he carroll
can push maybe maybe even without
all of the pieces and the queen maybe
just uh you know with the pawns but i i
think they'd be pushing it but it would
be fun to watch
so we'll see what they come up with uh
next and can
jimmy uh you know figure out how to win
a game against hikaru as i i think they
will be playing more matches so we'll
we'll see what happens there
uh so uh that's uh the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it as you can see jimmy
enjoyed it as well as he continued that
game even though
he could have just resigned but he
continued for for our enjoyment
uh i would like to thank uh uh wayoyon
min uh andres boots uh deadlift plus
house
uh harry lewin and curtis fox for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day